so there's a protest going on in Ireland
right now did you see this yeah what was
that about apparently there was a dude
that stabbed someone I don't really know
I he alerian immigrants there's an
immigrant that stab that went there to
Ireland I don't know if he was legal if
he came through was like Refugee status
but basically stabbed someone and now
people are pissed off that they're just
letting people into the country that are
doing violent acts so what's the deal
protest bucking off people are going
crazy McGregor is like very outspoken
and like telling people his opinions he
seems like pretty diplomatic about it
but he's very much like youo let's lock
it down what's going on you know you
know what's funny is that uh there's
been like a series of
um elections where the quote unquote
like extreme right candidate has either
won or is gotten close to Wi close
winning right so this seems to be like a
trend yeah how much longer can you call
that the extreme right as opposed to
what people
want like do you know what I'm say like
you have to have a
different form of description if almost
the majority or the majority starts to
desire this right and I understand
you're labeling that way as a Prive
right you're trying to like insult these
people and their beliefs but if their
beliefs reflect what the people want
that is kind of public sentiment yeah
but it's the left labeling it it's
extreme right it's not the right saying
we are the extreme right mhm I think
that's a good point but I think media in
general and I don't want to like label
media in general as left even though
sometimes it might lean that way but
media media in general tends to call it
the extreme right which I don't know if
is the best term if it's becoming more
popular and I think it's a way to like I
I don't know if this is their goal but
they're kind of
um using it as a way to almost like
discredit them or make them Radioactive
but by doing that you're not listening
to what the people are concerned about
oh interesting you know what I'm saying
like whether or not they're right or
wrong there's still something that
they're like bothered by that isn't
being spoken to by the regular right or
the center or the left and I think it is
maybe better to like stop name calling
and start figuring out what the [__]
yeah listen to the people and why they
voted
that I'm saying
like we did that with Trump every Trump
support is a racist blah blah blah and
then all of a sudden this guy gets
elected and you're like why don't we
figure out why okay let's say he's
racist he's all these other things but
what is he to these people why do they
vote for him and then I can speak to
what you need better than I feel this
quote unquote racist guy can I think
that was a massive thing the leftist
didn't want to do it was just easy to
discredit him and then you end up
discrediting those people and those
people get frustrated they get more
frustrated and more emboldened to vote
for this guy and that party and [__] you
guys and less heard and just willing to
go for the guy that's like saying the
right [__] even if he doesn't have the
policy to back it up when you're not
hurt at all and somebody speaks to what
you're feeling yeah you can very easily
block out all the other [__] [__] they
say yep so you might as well just hear
these people listen listen to them and
then all of a sudden they won't feel
like there's only one option they'll
feel like every time they turn on the TV
they'll be like oh yeah wow I am
frustrated for that reason and you know
what I don't have to vote for this super
extreme guy because at least I am being
Hur and hopefully these other
politicians will listen to what's going
on now there is a certain percentage of
them that are going to be racist there's
a certain percentage of them that are
going to be anti-semitic there are going
to be islamophobes like that also exists
but to paint them with that brush yeah
that's where you get dangerous because
it does really make them go you know
what [__] you yeah you keep calling me
racist I'mma vote for that [__]
all right fine I'm I'm racist if I'm
already racist and I can't do nothing
about it fine I'mma vote for the guy who
cares about my farm yeah and it bothers
you and you bother me and label me as
all this stuff so [__] you as enough
reason voting for yeah yeah you see this
new dude in Argentina yeah with the
Sideburn chipmunk bro what what is up
with all these guys are having like the
same Vibe Hair what's his what's his
deals he I don't know I don't really
know can't trust guys with weird
haircuts man that that is they're always
up to something they are I mean the
whole vibe is crazy dud yeah that's wild
dude I mean crazy sideburns and then the
Dutch guys got the same same Vibe yeah
you saw you saw him who's that
yeah
yo this guy who is this he's the
Argentine prime minister or something
like that he just won the election he's
like guess a Libertarian he says he's
GNA shut down the Central Bank of
Argentina oh [__] oh good luck yeah
you're dead yeah immedately right low
key there's part of me that goes but
it's so [__] up on our part that what
cuz we're killing
him he's kind [__] up but the thing but
the thing that like you're St
with that like okay let's say for
example you have frustrations obviously
you know I saw one documentary and then
I freak out on the the central bank we
printed like how many trillion dollars
during covid and inflation went up like
what 10% a lot like in certain in
certain industries it went up 50 maybe
went 100 but overall inflation I think
went up they said like 8% or something
like
that Bravo Central Bank you know what I
mean well done fed like we can talk
about all the [__] that they do but they
managed the crisis while they [__]
Managed IT okay now Argentina might have
100% inflation one day the next day
there's no money in the [__] ATMs
their Central Bank if they are in charge
of monetary policy and it is on them to
make sure that they maintain the
Argentine currency and protect it over
the last whatever it is 2030 I don't
even know how long it is that they've
had these kind of Crisis if they keep
[__] up my man has every right to be
like yo they're not doing the job get
them out okay peace mhm if you say that
about America I need you to really
convince me because it's going to be
hard to convince the four of us sitting
right here whose money seems to be doing
okay yeah like yeah we're losing some
value to inflation but nothing compared
to what Argentina would lose if they
printed $2 trillion do in a [__]
pandemic so I do understand why he could
say something like that when he's
campaigning and people would be like
yeah [__] that bank cuz one day I had
$100 now I got
and that sucks and if there's someone
who's in charge of that [__] and this
keeps happening get them yeah mhm am I
crazy to think that no that makes sense
crazy but he ain't going Li yeah I'm
curious how long he he holds out oh they
going to kill him go to priz pi.com use
a promo code Schultz they'll match your
initial entry of $100 up to that $100 so
you put 100 they're going to match up to
100 exactly that's beautiful you said
that better than me now listen we in
this together we're Team okay we are
teams go to prize.com get 100% deposit
match up to $10000 with the promo code
Schultz SZ you got this okay now let's
get back to the show